the world continues to mourn the death
of Stephen twitch boss the former
in-house DJ on The Ellen Degeneres Show
who tragically died at the age of 40
with his death being ruled a suicide
yeah we are still so shocked inside and
by this news more details are emerging
about his passing with TMZ reporting law
enforcement sources said that twitch's
wife Allison holker told them he'd left
their home unexpectedly before his death
she also said that he was not answering
any of her calls and according to E.T
twitch checked into the Oak Tree Inn on
Monday and when he didn't check out the
next morning Hotel staff found his body
on the floor TMZ also spoke with staff
at the motel who said that twitch didn't
seem visibly upset yeah and as tributes
continue to pour in from Hollywood and
all over we want to celebrate that smile
and inspiration that touched so many
yeah earlier this year Ellen surprised
her co-executive producer with a very
touching tribute to Showcase how much
his love and light changed her life and
the show as a whole
I'm supposed to be throwing a to a
montage right now of some of our
favorite celebrity moments but I'm not
going to do that over a decade ago I met
someone who changed my life and and our
show and I'm talking about you twitch
come here I love you so much and it's
been an emotional week and uh
I it's just a coincidence that your
mom's here like we didn't we were going
to do this and then you told me your
mom's here and your best friends here
and uh so
I just I just want to say this show is
just like just what happened just now
before we came back from break we do
those little tiny moments when we're
singing a song and you always make me
smile and laugh anyway we put a little
something together just to say how much
we all love you here I used to be a huge
fan of So You Think You Can Dance and I
wanted to do a dance so the producers of
So You Think You Can Dance set me up
with twitch twitch came over to my house
and he helped me try to copy it it was
like a crash course and getting to know
each other because and he was so patient
with me that was my initial love for him
was we just bonded over learning to
dance together fond memories are mainly
mainly waxing him it has to be number
one ready ready are you ready yes all
right oh my God
[Applause]
oh my God whenever he's not here for
whatever reason it's just different I
mean I I I count on him to to look over
at and make silly jokes and and he's my
pal you know he's my sidekick because
you know we have this we have this
connection so just looking over and and
he makes me laugh he really really makes
me laugh
this is just so sad we were just talking
about how this clip has gone viral
because this was just filmed back in May
and of course no one would know that we
would lose twitch and it's just really
really affecting people yeah I think his
energy his light his positivity it just
resonated with so many people he reached
so many people through dance through the
Ellen Degeneres Show and those are the
people that you don't think would ever
be going through something it's the
shock I think it's the shock value that
someone who came across so happy and
brought so much happiness to people
whether it was on the show or through
social media and the close body of his
kids and his wife I mean there's a video
of him and his wife just a couple of
days ago they look so happy so I think
there's that that shock element that
people are still trying to grasp
absolutely I think it's just so
important to know that behind the
biggest Smiles sometimes is the biggest
hurt
um so and you never know what's going on
in someone's life and that's why you
have to be kind to everybody and we need
to just break the stigma around mental
health I think especially in men people
of color we were raised as a black male
myself you were raised to be tough and
to fight and if you ask for help you're
weak and that's just ingrained in
society these days and there's such a
stigma around weakness and mental health
and it just needs to be eradicated in my
opinion I think that it's so important
that you're saying that I've been
hearing from a ton of people uh
conversation surrounding mental health
and the importance of getting help and
even when you do what that means and and
how that affects everyone around you and
how much people still you know there's
still that stigma you still want to keep
that very close to yourself so there's a
lot of conversations going on right now
it's really his death has really
affected a lot of people and I'm just my
heart goes out to this whole family